On va reprendre notre étude sur ces chapitres de la confession de foi qui parlent de la création.
On a déjà considéré la création de l'univers de manière générale,
et nous sommes en train de considérer la création de l'homme de manière particulière.
Donc l'affirmation principale au début de ces considérations,
c'était que les créationnismes littérales est une question confessionnelle.
Qu'est-ce que cela veut dire ?
Que pendant 2000 ans d'histoire, plus ou moins,
on a toujours interprété Genèse de manière littérale
dans ce qui est considéré comme christianisme historique.
C'est très récent, à cause de mauvaise compréhension de faire la distinction
entre les méthodes d'interprétation biblique d'un côté et de l'autre côté,
des théories scientifiques qui réclament presque dans la pratique être comme des lois.
Cette confusion a porté l'Église et les théologiens plus récents
à considérer des possibles conflits entre la vie et la science lorsqu'ils ne sont jamais arrivés.
Il n'y a jamais des contradictions entre la vraie science et la bonne interprétation biblique,
et nous ne devrions jamais sentir dans la menace des pressions, des théories,
sur notre interprétation biblique,
car les mêmes auteurs de la Bible sont l'auteurs de la création et ils seront toujours d'accord.
Et donc là, on est en train d'insister sur le fait que c'est impossible
d'en respectant les méthodes d'interprétation biblique
et les méthodes historiques d'interprétation biblique,
de ne pas considérer Genèse comme un récit historique littéral.
Et voilà, on a parlé de toutes ces implications.
On a aussi considéré, bien sûr, que la considération des origines n'est pas une considération exclusive de la religion,
et qu'il nous a retrouvé la théorie du créationnisme intelligent, d'origine divine,
comme même d'entre les discussions philosophiques et même scientifiques, la théorie la plus supportable.
Pour nous, ce n'est pas une question de théorie.
Si on croit que la Bible est la vérité de Dieu,
on est déjà devant une révélation suprême, objective, fiable,
du créationnisme littéral et confessionnel.
Donc ensuite, on est arrivé à la description des récits bibliques que nous présentent à la création.
Essentiellement, la création générale, globale, c'est une création fiat,
c'est-à-dire c'était un décret issu de la parole des dieux.
Dieu a déclaré que les choses soient faites et les choses ont été faites.
Dieu a décrété ces choses de manière glorieuse, miraculeuse, pour rendre une gloire à son nom.
Et il a fait tout à partir des liens.
Voilà pourquoi on défend la création par la classification latine.
C'est fiat, c'est-à-dire par décret, par parole, et ex-nirlo, c'est-à-dire à partir des liens.
Donc ça, c'est la description de la créationnisme littérale.
Si on veut revenir, rentrer dans les détails, on va parler de cette terre d'âge jaune,
les six jours littéral, etc.
Ensuite, on a commencé à considérer la création de l'homme,
la création comme en étant une création spéciale.
Donc on est en train de suivre tous les récits bibliques de la création.
Il y a un rythme très clair, mais il y a une pause, il y a une réunion entre trinitaires
et les trois personnes de la trinité se disent « faisons-nous l'homme, notre image,
comme notre rassemblement ».
Donc c'est une création spéciale.
Et on a considéré aussi la constitution de l'homme,
de quoi l'homme est composé dans sa constitution basique.
Donc l'âme et les corps ensemble, intégral,
possiblement la portion immatériale avec une légère distinction,
même s'ils sont prédominamment synonymes, esprit et âme,
mais avec des légères distinctions qu'on a considérées ensemble.
Et ensuite, ce qu'on va considérer aujourd'hui,
c'est l'homme à l'image des dieux.
Ou plutôt l'image des dieux par cette considération
qui est vraiment le cœur de ce qu'on appelle l'anthropologie biblique
et qui, à la fin des comptes, est la source la plus exacte
et la plus fiable de connaître ce qu'il y a l'homme.
Donc c'est encore un autre enjeu très important
qu'on ne fait pas trop attention quand on s'expose
à compromettre l'interprétation littérale des jeunesses,
nous ne percevons pas que nous sommes en train de risquer
de perdre toute la compréhension biblique à propos de l'homme.
Il y a beaucoup d'interactions,
non seulement envers la théorie de l'évolution,
mais aussi envers les théories psychanalystes de nos jours
ou psychologiques de nos jours
qui ne sont pas en train de considérer l'homme
comme étant constitué,
comme en étant dans son structure et dans son essence
un être tel qu'est décrit par la parole de Dieu.
Et voilà pourquoi ils sont très inefficaces
et leurs diagnostics ne sont pas exacts
car ils n'ont pas en train de considérer l'homme tel qu'il est,
ils ne peuvent pas comprendre vraiment
tel qu'est Dieu, les créateurs, les décrit,
quels sont, par exemple, les fonctionnements essentiels de l'homme,
quels sont ses démons les plus profondes,
quels sont les problèmes de l'homme.
Et donc si on s'éloigne de l'historicité littérale des jeunesses,
on s'éloigne de la compréhension de ce qu'il y a l'homme,
de l'anthropologie biblique,
qui est la source la plus fiable de connaître ce qu'il y a,
de comprendre ces crises.
Et donc ce n'est pas pour supprimer complètement
les intercessions possibles,
que la grâce commune permet qu'on aille,
par exemple la psychologie comportamentale
qui observe les comportements de l'homme.
Donc il y a pas mal d'interactions
qui peuvent être confirmées par la parole de Dieu,
mais dans les présupposés originales,
l'homme a été créé spécialement par Dieu,
pour Dieu,
et sans la considération de ce que Dieu aime
et ce que l'homme est tel qu'est fait par Dieu,
on n'a pas la capacité de régler les problèmes de l'homme
et de satisfaire l'homme humain.
Et donc il y a un enjeu très important
lié à l'interprétation littéraire de la justice.
La discussion ici n'est pas tout simplement
par rapport à l'âge de la terre,
terre vieille, terre nouvelle.
La question c'est est-ce que ces textes
doivent être interprétés de manière littérale ou non ?
Et on a vu plein d'implications, même théologiques,
car Christ nous est présenté comme les nouvelles Adam,
il faut avoir un Adam littéral original.
La chute par exemple,
c'est impossible de défendre par exemple les fossiles
avant l'apparition de l'homme,
car la Bible nous enseigne
que la mort ne peut pas rentrer dans l'univers
si ce n'est pas à partir de la chute humaine.
Et donc on va compromettre
toute la liaison parfaite
entre les doctrines bibliques
si nous sommes en train de mettre en question
l'aspect littéral de Genèse.
Et un de ces enjeux,
c'est tout simplement la compréhension
de ce qui vous êtes.
Et à partir de là,
un ensemble des connexions
envers plusieurs ères de la théologie.
Et voilà pourquoi je pense que c'est important
de nous rappeler de la pertinence
de l'anthropologie biblique,
car nous voulons faire l'Église
en mettant en question ça,
nous voulons penser à la sanctification
et en réalité,
tout est lié à l'anthropologie biblique,
car les grands problèmes de l'homme,
c'est sa séparation de Dieu,
lui qui a été créé pour Dieu,
et de se restaurer,
même dans la sanctification,
c'est de se restaurer
en revenant à la conformité
de l'image des dieux dans l'homme,
et bien sûr,
surtout centré sur Christ
à partir de cette œuvre de rédemption.
Et donc,
c'est important déjà
de considérer la crise existentielle actuelle,
malgré le développement
de ces sciences
ou de ces disciplines
ou de ces facultés,
si on peut dire comme ça,
qui cherchent à traiter la psyché de l'homme,
qui cherchent à traiter l'homme,
malgré le développement
de notre usage médical,
ou penser que ce dont l'homme a besoin,
c'est de plus de civilité
ou plus d'éducation.
On essaie de guérir
les problèmes de l'homme,
la crise d'existence de l'homme.
On essaie de donner
ou de chercher
à maintenir une dignité
chez l'homme.
On essaie de préserver
une espèce de dignité humaine
sans avoir,
dans les théories prédominantes aujourd'hui,
un support rationnel
pour défendre la dignité de l'homme.
Car si l'homme est le fruit d'une explosion,
s'il a développé d'un animal,
il n'a pas de dignité intrinsèque,
inhérente.
On ne peut pas défendre,
par exemple,
les crises morales de l'homme,
etc.
Et donc,
il y a un manque de support
pour préserver
ce qui reste
de la dignité de l'homme.
Il y a un manque
de connaissances objectives
de notre fonctionnement,
de notre constitution.
On va fragmenter l'être humain,
on va chercher
à guérir son physique,
parfois on va chercher
à guérir son émotionnel,
mais il n'y a pas
la compréhension exacte
d'où viennent
ces problématiques.
On est dans une profonde confusion
dans nos jours
par rapport à ce qu'ils ont développé
comme étant
une espèce d'identité sexuelle,
identité des genres,
en faisant la déconnexion
entre la biologie
et ce qui est l'être humain
dans son intégralité.
Il y a donc
une sensation générale
à partir des philosophies
surtout nihilistes,
relativistes,
où cette crise
est non seulement
une crise morale,
mais c'est une crise
aussi des significations,
c'est une crise
des manques
de satisfaction.
Et donc,
ça conduit
notre génération,
ou cette dernière génération,
à supprimer
ce qui est
la noblesse
de l'être humain,
ce qui est la dignité.
Donc,
c'est de sacrifier
la noblesse
de l'être humain
car,
par exemple,
nos aspirations
relationnelles,
personnelles,
les affections,
l'amour
n'ont pas de sens
si on est les fruits
d'une énergie
qui ne pense pas,
qui n'a pas de sentiments,
qui n'a pas de raisonnement,
etc.
Et donc,
ça c'est déjà,
ça montre la pertinence
de nous accrocher
à une anthropologie biblique,
aussi quand on considère
tout simplement
la notion
de l'autoconnaissance
et de la connaissance
de Dieu.
Donc,
nous avons la capacité
de connaître Dieu
car on a été créé
par Dieu,
pour Dieu,
à l'image de Dieu.
Et donc,
quelque part,
il n'y a pas
de connaissance humaine
sans la connaissance
de Dieu.
C'est impossible
de se connaître
sans avoir connu
Dieu lui-même,
sans prendre en considération
les faits
qui nous sont créés
à l'image de Dieu.
Donc,
ça c'est très important.
La première réponse
de la question
du catéchisme,
du petit catéchisme
de Westminster
qui nous demande
par rapport
à la fin principale
de l'homme,
quelle est la réponse ?
Quelle est la fin principale
de l'homme ?
Glorifier Dieu
et se réjouir en lui.
Et donc,
c'est vivre
pour obéir
à l'objectif
de notre création,
rendre gloire à Dieu,
être représentant
de Dieu,
image de Dieu
et nous réjouir en Dieu
car Dieu nous a créés
pour lui.
Donc,
ça,
c'est la signification
la plus sublime
qu'on puisse imaginer
pour l'être humain
en termes des fonctions
et en termes d'être
des relations.
Les problèmes
de l'homme
ne peuvent pas
être compris non plus.
Voilà pourquoi
on est tellement superficiel
dans les essais
de traiter
nos manques
de satisfaction
ou la coupabilité.
Ce sont les deux crises
fondamentales
de l'être humain.
C'est-à-dire,
nous sommes coupables
de notre transgression
mais en même temps,
nos transgressions
nous ont privés
de lasser
à la seule chose
ou la seule personne
qui est capable
de remplir
notre âme
des joies.
Et donc,
voilà,
les problèmes fondamentaux
de l'homme,
c'est coupabilité
d'un côté,
insatisfaction
de l'autre,
les deux ensemble
et les deux choses
ne peuvent être comprises
que par la considération
du fait que Dieu
nous a créés pour lui
et notre rébellion
contre Dieu
nous a privés
de la signification
même de notre être
et de la satisfaction
de ce qui nous sommes.
Donc, par exemple,
quand on va voir
dans la parole
des dieux,
les diagnostics bibliques,
c'est qu'il n'y a pas
un seul juste,
tous ont été privés
des dieux,
privés de la gloire
des dieux.
C'est ça,
les diagnostics fondamentaux.
on a plusieurs symptômes
de cette problématique
qui vont s'afficher
dans nos vies,
mais à la racine,
c'est la séparation
des dieux,
la séparation
de ceux qui nous sommes
et donc la réconciliation
avec Dieu
est une réconciliation
envers nous-mêmes
et envers les mondes
que Dieu a créés.
Donc, tout cela
est enraciné
dans les récits
créationnels
littéraux
des jeunesses.
Un autre aspect,
c'est la compréhension
de la rédemption
elle-même.
Donc,
l'évangile
nous est présenté
en termes
des premiers Adam,
du deuxième Adam.
Christ,
l'image parfaite
directe des dieux
et nous,
une copie
quelque part
de cette image.
Donc,
les langages
qui présentent
la rédemption
de la Bible
en termes
d'image des dieux,
elle décrit
vraiment
la compréhension
essentielle
de la rédemption.
Donc,
pour comprendre
l'évangile lui-même,
c'est important
de préserver
la compréhension
de l'image des dieux.
Pour comprendre
la sanctification,
c'est la même chose,
c'est d'être restauré
à l'image des dieux
et particulièrement
à l'image du Christ.
C'est ça,
la sanctification
selon la Bible.
Pour l'évangélisation,
c'est la même chose.
Quand on va
en acte 17,
c'est tellement intéressant
de remarquer
comment Paul
va lier
la proclamation
de l'évangile
aux perdus païens
en Athènes
avec la conception
du fait
qu'ils savaient
qu'ils étaient
race des dieux,
quelque part,
image des dieux.
Et c'est ça,
le problème.
On a été créé
pour trouver dieux
peut-être en tâtonnant,
c'est le langage de Paul,
et la réalité,
c'est qu'il n'est pas
loin de nous
car en lui,
nous avons les mouvements
et l'être.
Et lorsque Paul
va décrire
cette problématique
en roman 1 à 3,
il va parler
l'aspect
insupprimable
de l'image
des dieux
dans l'homme
car même
dans notre conscience,
la seule explication
pour la moralité
qui reste encore,
même si corrompue
dans l'être humain,
c'est le fait
que cette conscience
nous a été donnée
car la loi des dieux
est enregistrée
dans notre cœur.
Donc,
même les impis
démontrent
connaître la loi
à cet égard.
Donc,
tous sont inexcusables
et donc,
pour l'évangélisation,
nous ne pouvons pas
être concentrés
tout simplement
dans les maquillages
du mort,
quelque part.
On suggère
que l'évangile,
parfois,
est juste
l'amélioration
dans la vie.
On va diriger
une évangélisation
dans la direction
de l'amélioration
de sa santé,
parfois,
l'amélioration
de son mariage,
de son succès
professionnel,
mais la réalité,
c'est que nous sommes
en train de nous
diriger vers
les symptômes
de péché,
mais la racine
du problème,
c'est réconciliation
avec Dieu
pour être réconcilié
avec soi-même.
Et donc,
l'évangélisation,
on ne peut pas
confondre
les possibles
conséquences
de la conversion,
les changements
que Dieu peut apporter
dans nos vies
à travers la conversion,
avec ce qui est
véritablement
l'évangile
ou l'évangélisation.
Donc,
ça,
c'est un problème
de l'Église
dans nos jours.
Donc,
il y a cette notion
des significations
pour la vie,
responsabilité
et redébabilité
pour vivre
pour la gloire
des dieux.
Quand on pense
à la sanctification,
par là,
on va traiter
la restauration
à l'image des dieux
telle qu'il est
constituée aussi
à l'origine
et on va penser
même à l'implication
du fait que Dieu
a créé l'homme
à l'image des dieux.
Homme et femme,
il les a créés
dans une relation
complémentaire
en respectant
ces choses.
Donc,
on va voir comment
dans la Bible,
la conception
des sanctifications,
Ephésiens 5 par exemple,
passe par la restauration
aussi du fonctionnement
de l'homme
tel qu'il fonctionne
en tant qu'homme
dans ses particularités,
de la femme
en tant qu'homme
dans ses particularités
et ça nous apporte
à une grande confrontation
à ce que notre génération
nous proposerait
à nos jours.
Donc,
ça,
c'est important aussi
de considérer
la pertinence
car si on est en train
d'exposer
l'interprétation
littérale
des génères
au compromis,
on risque de perdre
l'image des dieux
et on va perdre
toutes ces airs-là
dont je suis en train
de parler,
y compris
l'éthique
au sein de l'Église,
la notion
des discipula,
d'enseignement,
les interactions
avec la société
et la politique,
avec toutes ces
visions différentes
de ce qu'est l'homme
et les problèmes
de l'homme
et la réalité,
c'est qu'à la fin
de compte,
nous sommes devant
quelque part
l'une des compréhensions
ou des conceptions
quand on pense
à l'image des dieux
les plus centrales
des écritures.
Donc,
c'est intéressant,
je vais vous lire
un commentaire
d'Antony Roquema.
Il dit le suivant,
si,
comme l'enseigne la Bible,
la chose la plus importante
concernant l'homme
est qu'il est
inévitablement
en relation avec Dieu,
nous devons considérer
comme déficientes
toute anthropologie
qui nie
cette relation
avec Dieu.
Toute anthropologie
qui nie
cette relation
avec Dieu.
Donc,
il faut qu'on soit
très attentif,
qu'on soit
très sage
pour filtrer
si jamais
on va croiser
avec des disciplines
qui se proposent
à traiter
l'âme humaine
mais qui n'a pas
ses fondements,
cette base
pour comprendre
ce qui est
l'être humain.
et donc là,
toute anthropologie
qui ne considère
pas l'image
de Dieu,
l'homme
en tant qu'image
de Dieu
est en train
de présenter
une anthropologie
déficiente
par rapport
à l'être humain.
Donc,
nous sommes en train
de considérer
l'anthropologie
biblique
et l'argument
principal,
là je vais citer
Lloyd-Jones,
il dit
que toute
la révélation
biblique
par laquelle
Dieu se révèle
à l'homme
afin de les réconcilier
et de les restaurer
avec lui-même
provient évidemment
du fait
que l'homme
a été créé
à l'origine
de telle manière
qu'il est devenu
le sujet
de cette révélation
et de cette rédemption.
C'est-à-dire
la thématique
de l'image
de Dieu
est une thématique
tellement fondamentale
qui va apparaître
en Genèse chapitre 1
et qui va dicter
l'un des thèmes
centrales
des Écritures.
Toutes les Écritures
vont tourner autour
quelque part
de cette restauration
de la relation
de l'homme
qui a été créée
à l'image des dieux
et la restauration
de l'image des dieux
dans l'homme.
Et donc,
on a
plusieurs versets bibliques
qui démontrent
de manière très explicite
l'importance
de cette emphase
et comment
nous ne pouvons pas
la négocier,
la compromettre
dans notre traitement biblique.
Donc,
quand la Bible
nous enseigne
que les saluts
et la restauration
de l'homme
envers Dieu,
la réconciliation
de l'homme
avec Dieu,
elle est en train
de nous enseigner aussi
que la restauration
de l'homme,
c'est une restauration
envers lui-même.
Sa réconciliation
avec Dieu,
c'est la réconciliation
de son sens d'existence,
de sa signification,
de son but.
Et c'est de restaurer aussi
non seulement sa relation
avec Dieu,
avec lui-même,
mais avec ses semblables
et les mondes,
car Dieu nous a placés
dans ces mondes
pour fonctionner
comme en représentant
des dieux
pour toute la création.
Et donc,
je vais vous présenter
quelques passages
qui sont des passages capitaux
et qui nous montrent
de manière très explicite
l'importance
de la thématique
de l'image des dieux.
Donc,
par exemple,
Genèse 1,
26 et 27,
puis Dieu dit
faisons l'homme
à notre image
selon notre rassemblance,
qu'il domine
sur les poissons de la mer,
les oiseaux du ciel,
sur les bétails,
sur toute la terre
et sur tous les reptiles
qui rampent sur la terre.
Et Dieu créa
l'homme à son image,
il les créa
à l'image des dieux,
il créa
l'homme
et la femme.
Tout cela doit être
considéré
comme très important
pour la compréhension
de ce qu'il y a
l'être humain
en tant qu'image des dieux.
Ensuite,
si on revient
à Genèse,
chapitre 5,
verset 1 à 3,
donc,
quelles sont
les implications
et quelle est l'importance
de l'image des dieux.
Voici les livres
de la postérité d'Adam.
Les jours où Dieu
créa l'homme,
il les fit
à la ressemblance
des dieux.
Il créa l'homme
et la femme
et les bénit
et il leur donna
les noms d'hommes
lorsqu'il fut créé.
Adam vécu
130 ans
et il engendra
un fils
à sa ressemblance
selon son image,
il l'appela 7.
Donc là,
il est en train
de réclamer historiquement
une généalogie
qui remonte à Adam
et qui confirme
de manière historique,
donc c'est une interprétation
biblique
qui fait une interprétation
historique
des textes précédents.
Donc on n'a pas
d'image
pour être en désaccord
avec une interprétation
intra-biblique.
Mais l'important ici,
c'est de renforcer
l'aspect
que l'homme
a été créé
à l'image
de Dieu.
Genèse 9,
verset 6,
celui qui répandra
les sangs
de l'homme
par l'homme
son sang
sera répandu
et quelle est
la base
de cette peine capitale
dans un contexte
encore
théocratique
quelque part,
c'est celui
qui répandra
les sangs
de l'homme
par l'homme
son sang
sera répandu
car Dieu
a fait l'homme
à son image.
Donc,
d'où vient
la considération
de l'aspect sacré
de la vie,
de la dignité humaine.
C'est de considérer
que de faire
du mal
mortel
contre l'homme,
c'est de faire
le mal
contre les représentants
de l'homme.
Juste pour avoir
une idée,
les langages
d'image
et ressemblance,
ça remonte
par exemple
à l'exercice
des rois
dans les temps anciens,
dans les anciens
par exemple,
Nabucodonosor,
comment vous vous appelez ?
Nabucodonosor.
Ok,
donc Nabucodonosor
qui va faire
une statue
et donc,
c'est une manière
d'étendre
son influence
et son autorité
afin que les personnes
qui croient
à cette statue
puissent se plier
afin de respecter
et renforcer
sa présence
là où il ne peut pas
être physiquement.
Et donc,
quelque part,
c'est ça
le rôle de l'homme
et de faire
des attaques
contre l'âme humaine
et pratiquer
par exemple
l'avortement,
c'est de vouloir
supprimer
Dieu lui-même.
Des chercher
à tuer
honnêtement,
c'est de chercher
à tuer
Dieu lui-même.
Et donc,
bien sûr,
quand on rentrera
dans le Nouveau Testament,
on peut considérer
quels seraient
les détails
par rapport
au support
ou non
d'une peine capitale
pour
les cas
d'assassinat.
Donc,
c'est une discussion
qu'on peut discuter
à partir du Nouveau Testament.
moment,
mais c'est clair
que cette peine capitale
est fondée
sur une valeur,
une considération
qui est perpétuelle,
la dignité
de l'être humain
en tant qu'image
de Dieu.
Et donc,
là,
c'est une discussion
pour un autre moment,
peut-être pour une séance
de questions et réponses,
mais pour l'instant,
il faut voir
l'importance capitale
du fait que Dieu
a fait l'homme
à son image
à point
que celui
qui porterait
un attentat
contre la vie
d'un autre
serait digne
d'une peine
des morts.
Ensuite,
nous bénissons
Dieu le Père,
donc Jacques 3, 9,
nous bénissons
Dieu le Père
et nous maudissons
les hommes
faits à l'image
des dieux.
Donc là,
il est en train
de parler
du péché
de la langue
et il est en train
de rappeler
qu'il a tout
à l'image
été fait
des dieux.
Et donc là,
c'est très important
de voir plusieurs
textes bibliques
qui vont revenir
sur la notion
d'image des dieux
pour défendre
ce qu'il y a
des plus nobles,
des plus importants
pour considérer
à propos de la valeur
de l'être humain.
Ephésiens 4, 24
et ce qui est intéressant
à remarquer
dans ces deux passages,
c'est indépendamment
de la régénération,
c'est-à-dire même
les êtres humains
dans son état perdu,
nous sommes devant
la préservation
de cette valeur
fondée sur l'image
des dieux
qui même
après la chute,
même si corrompue,
radicalement corrompue,
et tordue,
n'est pas complètement
supprimée.
Donc,
Ephésiens 4, 24,
revêtez-vous,
pardon,
tous les textes
que j'avais mentionnés
avant,
c'était indépendamment
du salut
de la régénération.
Ça parlait
de tous les êtres humains,
y compris pour la peine
des morts.
Et là,
ici,
là,
on parle plutôt
des textes
qui parlent
de la sanctification
et de la régénération.
Donc,
Ephésiens 4, 24,
revêtez-vous
de l'homme nouveau,
créez selon Dieu,
dans la justice
et la sainteté
qui produit
la vérité.
Donc,
revêtez-vous
de l'homme nouveau,
créez selon Dieu,
dans la justice
et dans la sainteté
qui produit la vérité.
Donc,
là,
à nouveau,
la restauration
de l'image
de Dieu,
créez selon Dieu
ou recréez selon Dieu.
Et Colossiens 3, 10,
et en ayant
révêtu l'homme nouveau
qui se rénouvelle
dans la connaissance
selon l'image
de celui
qui l'a créé.
Donc,
c'est clair
que,
de manière plus intentionnelle,
les Nouveaux Testaments
vont nous diriger
à récréer cette image
dans la direction du Christ.
Mais c'est important
de remarquer
que les Nouveaux Testaments
lui-même
ne font pas
des dissociations
entre l'essence
de cette image
originelle
qui était déjà
l'image des dieux
et cette image
qui, bien sûr,
sera rajoutée
des valeurs
avec Christ,
mais qui est
dans la même essence
l'image des dieux.
Donc,
la raison
principale
pour considérer
l'image
des dieux
dans l'homme,
c'est notamment
la place centrale
qu'elle occupe
dans l'ensemble
de la révélation biblique
de l'enseignement biblique.
Et donc,
c'est lié au fait
que l'homme
a été constitué
à l'image des dieux.
Donc,
voilà pourquoi
c'est important
pour nous
de considérer
l'image des dieux.
Voilà la pertinence.
Donc,
ce qu'on a déjà fait,
c'était de considérer
la création
de l'homme
et la constitution.
Donc,
je vous encourage
à revenir
si vous n'étiez pas là.
Pour rappel,
c'était une création
spéciale
parmi la création
générale.
Donc,
Dieu va s'arrêter
au sixième jour,
la pause,
les sommets,
tout ce qui a été
préparé avant,
c'était pour placer
l'homme
quelque part au centre.
C'était une création
selon son image.
directe des dieux
à partir de la poussière.
et complétée
par les souffles divins.
Donc,
c'est un simple
qu'il y a l'homme.
Il a occupé
une position
d'absolue priorité
envers tous les restes
de la création
et une seule race humaine
a été créée,
composée par un couple
de sexualité complémentaire.
Donc,
ce sont les choses
qu'on a considérées
par rapport à la création
spéciale de l'homme.
Il n'a pas été créé
selon son espèce.
Il a été créé
selon Dieu.
Ensuite,
on a considéré aussi
la constitution
de l'homme.
Donc là,
on a parlé
de combien spécial
a été la création
de l'homme
et ensuite,
on a parlé
de la constitution
de l'homme.
Et donc,
on a considéré
que l'homme
est un être intégral,
indivisible,
composé d'une portion
matérielle
et d'une portion
spirituelle.
Et même si,
après la mort,
nous continuons
d'exister
par la portion
spirituelle,
il y aura
pour tous les êtres
humains
une résurrection
finale
qui va nous réunir
à nos corps
et qui va les élever
à une condition
si on va vers
les ciels
où nous serons
davantage capables
de réjouir
des réalités célestes
et pour ceux
qui vont à l'enfer
pour avoir
une capacité
de résister davantage
aux punitions
ou de souffrir
sans être détruit
les punitions
réservées
pour toute l'éternité.
Et donc,
la réalité,
c'est que c'est un être
intégral,
indivisible,
mais qui est composé
d'une portion
matérielle
et d'une portion
spirituelle
et pour certains,
nous ne devons
ne pas faire
la différence
radicale
entre âme
et esprit,
mais il y a
plusieurs emphases bibliques
qui semblent donner
une prééminence
des fonctionnalités
à l'âme
ou à l'esprit
et l'esprit
étant cette portion
qui nous lie
plus à Dieu,
qui est plus versée
vers les relations
spirituelles
et qui parfois
est présentée
comme ce qui est
opéré en nous
au moment où
nous sommes convertis,
c'est d'être né
de nouveau
en termes d'esprit.
Donc,
c'est la mort
spirituelle
ou la régénération
spirituelle.
Mais dans la plupart
des cas,
âme et esprit
sont interchangeables.
On a aussi parlé
des théories
liées
à la notion
de l'origine
de l'âme.
OK ?
Et donc,
on a considéré
quelle est la constitution
de l'être humain.
Donc,
il y a
chez l'être humain
à l'origine
surtout
un équilibre
parfait
entre ses facultés
spirituelles
et ses compositions
humaines,
physiques.
Voilà pourquoi
notre condition physique
peut jouer
sur nos émotions.
Nos émotions
peuvent jouer aussi
sur notre condition physique
et la question spirituelle
est celle
qui devrait être
la plus capable
par notre scientification,
par notre spiritualité,
d'y porter
la gouvernance
et de réordonner
les choses
afin qu'on vit
une vie
qui soit
plus agréable,
plus satisfaisante,
plus selon
l'ordre des dieux.
Donc là,
on a considéré
cette réalité
de l'homme.
Et donc là,
pour entrer
de manière plus objective
à la considération
de l'image
des dieux
dans l'homme,
nous allons retourner
au texte de Genèse
pour faire
une espèce
de survol
sur les passages.
Et pourquoi
c'est important
de commencer par là ?
Déjà,
c'est la Bible,
mais c'est important
car il y a
plusieurs aspects
assez mystérieux
quand on essaye
de comprendre
l'image de Dieu.
On essaye
d'identifier
quels sont
ces aspects,
ces facultés,
etc.
On essaye
de bien comprendre
ces choses,
mais il y a aussi
les risques
d'être trop
disséquer la chose,
d'être trop séparé
de la chose.
Et donc ici,
c'est un contexte
plus naturel
où nous ne pouvons
pas perdre de vue
l'ensemble
des choses décrites
ici comme en étant
partie,
composante,
de cette image
de Dieu dans
l'homme.
Verset 26,
puis Dieu dit
faisons l'homme
à notre image
selon notre
rassemblance.
Donc ces deux
termes sont
importants,
il n'y a pas
de distinctions
radicales
entre eux,
mais il y a
des nuances
importantes à
considérer.
Et qu'ils
dominent,
donc là,
c'est clair
que cette notion
de domination,
donc il y a
la notion
d'être l'image
des dieux,
d'être
à l'assemblance
des dieux,
et des dominés.
C'est-à-dire
quand on voit
les textes
tels qu'il est
devant nous,
il y a une notion
d'être,
des représentations
par ces termes
rassemblances,
c'est-à-dire
les capacités
et qu'ils dominent,
c'est-à-dire
cette expression,
cette fonction
qui s'est exercée
est une fonction
qui accomplit
le but d'être
image des dieux.
C'est pour ne pas
diviser,
on va dire,
ce que l'homme
est de ce que
l'homme fait
comme si l'homme
pourrait être
sans faire
et être complètement.
La réalité,
c'est que l'homme,
il est un agent
qui doit faire
car Dieu
est aussi une personne
qui fait des choses.
Et donc,
la réalité,
c'est que nous avons ici
la notion
de cette domination,
c'est pour agir
comme un petit dieux
dans cette création
en ayant cette autorité,
cette domination,
cette gouvernance
et c'est une gouvernance
qui devrait être exercée
selon la gouvernance
des dieux,
c'est-à-dire
pour les biens
de la création.
Et donc,
la dominance
sur tous ces êtres,
verset 27,
Dieu créa l'homme
à son image,
donc c'est une gouvernance
qui sera exercée,
mais une gouvernance
qui sera exercée
par des êtres
qui ont été créés
à l'image des dieux
et ces êtres,
l'homme et la femme,
chacun,
possèdent
cette faculté
ou ces facultés
plus réelles
qui font
qui nous sont reconnus
individuellement même
comme image des dieux,
mais qui fait
que par l'interaction
complémentaire,
nous soyons
davantage capables
de vivre l'image
des dieux
et de manifester
l'image des dieux.
Car notre dieu
est un dieu pluriel,
est un dieu,
famille,
si on peut dire
comme ça,
et c'est de cette manière
que nous,
on a été créés.
Et donc là,
Dieu créa l'homme
à son image,
il est créé
à l'image des dieux,
il créa homme et femme.
Donc c'est-à-dire
que la considération
de ce qui détermine
les particularités
et les complémentarités
entre l'homme
et la femme
sont très importantes
pour que nous puissions
fonctionner comme image
des dieux.
À partir du moment
où la femme
ne marche pas
comme une femme
devrait marcher
ou un homme
ne marche pas
comme un homme
devrait marcher,
il sera en train
de jouer
contre l'image
des dieux
qui devrait être.
Ensuite,
Dieu les bénit,
donc là,
il y a cet aspect
d'une relation
d'amour
entre Dieu
et l'homme,
donc Dieu
qui va bénir
l'être humain
et par là,
nous allons reconnaître
cet aspect spirituel
de cette relation
avec Dieu
et Dieu leur dit
« Soyez féconds,
multipliez,
remplissez la terre. »
Donc à nouveau,
c'est un ordre
qui n'a jamais été révoqué.
Donc pour plus
qu'on traverse
des moments
très difficiles
dans notre génération,
des défis financiers,
etc.,
« Soyez féconds,
multipliez,
remplissez la terre,
c'est un mandat. »
Ensuite,
et là,
on appelle ça
les mandats sociaux,
on va revenir sur ça,
« Assujettissez
et dominez,
donc là,
c'est les mandats
qu'on appelle
un mandat culturel
sur les poissons
de la mer,
les oiseaux,
etc.,
tous les animaux
et toute la terre. »
Et donc,
Dieu pourvoit
la nourriture
et donc,
il est dans ces passages,
on n'a pas le temps
de rentrer dans les détails,
mais il est dans ces passages
non seulement
en train de donner
l'ordre à l'homme,
mais il est en train
de démontrer à l'homme
comment lui,
il a structuré les choses
pour que l'homme
ait non seulement
l'obligation
d'être les représentants
de Dieu,
d'imiter Dieu
dans sa gouvernance,
mais qu'il sache aussi
en observant
la manière dont Dieu
a organisé les mondes,
suivre les paramètres
de Dieu
pour exercer
cette gouvernance
dans sa relation
avec lui-même,
avec Dieu
et envers
les mondes créés.
Et donc ensuite,
Dieu vit
que tout ce qu'il avait fait,
tout ce qu'il avait fait
et voici,
cela était très bon.
Donc là,
tout ce qu'il a vu avant
était bon
et maintenant,
tout est très bon.
Ainsi,
il y a eu un soir,
un matin,
ce fut le sixième jour.
Au chapitre 2,
au départ,
nous allons remarquer
au verset 3,
Dieu bénit les septième jour
et il les sanctifia
parce qu'en ces jours,
il se reposa
de toute son œuvre
qu'il avait créée
en la faisant.
Et donc,
dans ces passages,
c'est important aussi
de les remarquer,
les sabbats
qui seraient préservés
pour toujours,
quelque part,
un jour sur sept.
Pour nous,
aujourd'hui,
c'est les dimanches,
mais ces jours sur sept,
à la création,
avant la chute,
c'était surtout les sabbats
car tout était parfait,
mais c'était ces moments
des communions avec Dieu.
Donc,
il y a ces mandats principaux
qui sont les mandats spirituels
qui étaient un jour
des réjouissances particulières
de la présence de Dieu,
un jour des satisfactions
de l'âme,
mais qui étaient un jour aussi,
quelque part,
des rédivabilités devant Dieu.
L'être humain
qui sortait
pour accomplir ses fonctions
dans ses relations maritales
et dans sa relation culturelle,
dans son interaction culturelle,
et qui devrait revenir
les sabbats
pour exprimer
toute sa reconnaissance à Dieu,
émerveiller,
car il n'y avait pas encore
les péchés,
d'avoir vécu
cette semaine
de manière parfaite,
en réjouissant
du travail qu'il produisait,
de la culture qu'il faisait,
de sa relation
avec son épouse,
et à partir de là,
il révénait les sabbats
pour louer Dieu,
pour exprimer les connaissances,
mais pour être aussi rédivable.
Comment nous avons vécu
cette semaine
en tant qu'image de Dieu ?
C'est la même question
qu'on doit se poser
à chaque dimanche
quand on revient à l'église.
Et donc,
par ces survols,
je pense que
l'objectif,
c'est de voir
de quelle manière
tous ces aspects
que j'évoquais
sont interconnectés,
et c'est pour nous protéger
de ne pas faire
des interprétations
à propos
de l'image
des dieux
dans l'homme
qui soient très fragmentées.
Et à partir de là,
je voulais proposer
qu'on revienne
sur la confession
des fois,
car elle va présenter
d'une manière
un peu plus organisée
ces mêmes vérités
qu'on vient de considérer.
Donc là,
si on lit ensemble
les deuxièmes paragraphes,
quand on a déjà traité
les premiers,
que c'était la création générale,
les deuxièmes paragraphes
traitent
plutôt
l'aspect
de l'image
des dieux
dans l'homme.
Voici ce qui dit le texte.
Après avoir fait
toutes les autres créatures,
Dieu créa l'homme,
il les créa
mâles et femelles
avec des âmes
raisonnables
et immortelles
qui les rendaient
propres
à cette vie
avec Dieu
pour laquelle
ils avaient été créés.
Ils ont été faits
à l'image des dieux
en connaissance,
justice
et vraie santé
ayant
la loi des dieux
inscrits
dans leur cœur
et les pouvoirs
de l'accomplir.
Ils avaient
cependant
la possibilité
de la transgresser
puisqu'ils étaient laissés
à la liberté
de leur propre volonté
qui était capable
des changements.
Il y a plusieurs
éléments
à reconnaître.
Donc l'objectif
de cette confession
c'est de mettre
en emphase,
en évidence,
quelques éléments
qui composent
la notion
de l'image
des dieux
dans l'homme.
C'est intéressant
de remarquer
comment
c'est une description
assez naturelle.
Il n'y a pas
une préoccupation
ici à trop classifier
et à trop séparer
les choses
mais les éléments
ressortent
assez clairement.
Donc déjà
il y a à nouveau
cette notion
d'avoir été créé
mâle et fémel
à l'image des dieux.
Donc la même valeur
on peut dire
comme ça.
les mêmes facultés
les mêmes capacités
les mêmes attributs
quelque part
des âmes
raisonnables
et immortelles
donc par là
on voit déjà
comment l'être humain
peut quelque part
imiter Dieu
ou être un réflet
de Dieu
donc nous sommes
des êtres raisonnables
et nous sommes
des êtres
immortels.
Donc Dieu
il est éternel
il n'a pas
un commencement
et il n'a pas
de fin.
Nous on a un commencement
mais on n'aura
pas de fin
et à cet égard-là
on est aussi
similaire
à Dieu.
Donc c'est intéressant
de remarquer
que ces facultés
étaient nécessaires
pour être propre
à cette vie
avec Dieu
et donc quelque part
quand on pense
à l'image des dieux
il faut qu'on imagine
qu'avant de pouvoir
refléter
ce qui Dieu est
nous avons besoin
non seulement
d'avoir les capacités
d'être tel qu'est Dieu
mais nous avons besoin
de contempler Dieu
et d'avoir cette relation
avec Dieu
afin de pouvoir
exprimer
ou refléter
cette image.
Donc devant
un miroir
s'il n'y a personne
devant le miroir
il n'y a pas
de reflet
et l'être humain
ne peut pas être
un reflet
sans qu'il soit
en face
des dieux
quelque part.
Et donc là
les âmes
sont raisonnables
immortelles
propres
à la vie
avec Dieu
à l'image
des dieux
en connaissance
justice
et vraie sainteté
donc ça
c'est l'homme
à l'origine
donc
sa part
de cette connaissance
qui va au-delà
d'une connaissance
théorique
c'est cette connaissance
des relations
cette justice
et cette vraie sainteté
ayant la loi des dieux
inscrite dans leur cœur
et donc là
Paul va dire
que même après la chute
il y a les restes
et la loi
qui est dans les cœurs
au ment
qui est là
pour les condamner
et qui est là
aussi pour
pour faire
que même
malgré sa corruption
il continue
quelque part
de garder
superficiellement
un comportement
qui ne soit pas
si bestial
comme il ne pourrait être
et la réalité
c'est que la loi
inscrite dans leur cœur
ici
c'est surtout
pour mettre en évidence
l'état original
et les pouvoirs
de l'accomplir
donc là
c'est la distinction
à l'état original
la loi était dans les cœurs
et les pouvoirs
de l'accomplir
y étaient aussi
après la corruption
du péché
ça reste inscrit
dans les cœurs
mais on peut effacer
supprimer
cautériser
à cause de la suppression
humaine
de la carnalité humaine
de la rébellion humaine
par contre
on n'a plus la capacité
de l'accomplir
la liberté
de leur propre volonté
est aussi évoquée
dans ces passages
et donc là
à nouveau
c'est important
de nous rappeler
que cette liberté
de volonté
n'était présente
que
à l'état
original
de l'homme
car aujourd'hui
l'homme
n'a plus
de liberté
de volonté
car la liberté
à avoir
avec
la capacité
d'accomplir
volontairement
et librement
non seulement
ce que je veux faire
mais c'est de choisir
pour ce qui est
le mieux
pour moi
car il y a
une relation
essentielle
entre la volonté
et ce qui
je crois être
le mieux pour moi
quelque part
donc
C.S. Lewis
il a dit
que même la personne
qui veut
se suicider
quelque part
son envie
c'est de sortir
d'une condition
qu'elle juge
très tragique
pour sa vie
dans les présents
donc il est en train
de chercher
à travers
cette décision
tragique
une meilleure
condition
après
donc il y a
une relation
entre la volonté
dans le sens
où on pense
que nous allons
trouver le mieux
pour nous
à travers
l'exercice
de la volonté
et la réalité
c'est que
la volonté
originale
c'était une volonté
qui n'est souffert
par les penchants
du péché
et la Bible décrit
l'être humain
dans sa condition
présente
comme étant
esclave du péché
sa volonté
est pliée
vers les mâles
contre Dieu
et la réalité
c'est qu'aujourd'hui
les hommes sont
responsables
de leur choix
ils font des choix
libres
selon leur volonté
mais le problème
c'est que comme
leur volonté
est corrompue
cette volonté
est exercée
toujours dans
une direction
d'esclavage
de la carnalité
de péché
de la corruption
de l'auto
destruction
et la réalité
c'est qu'avec
la régénération
nous resterons
partiellement
ce qu'on appelle
les libres arbitres
mais les libres arbitres
n'est pas une réalité
hors la conversion
n'est pas en réalité
hors la création
originale
c'était la capacité
de juger
d'arbitrer
sans avoir
aucune influence
qui nous portait
envers les péchés
donc la réalité
c'est que la volonté
est corrompue
et l'être humain
ne peut pas choisir
pour Dieu
par exemple
après sa rébellion
il est décrit
comme mort spirituellement
mort pour Dieu
fils des colères
fils de la rébellion
c'est la description
biblique
de la condition
de l'homme
après la chute
donc la réalité
c'est qu'il avait
la capacité
d'exercer
un jugement
libre d'interférence
avec la connaissance
suffisante
nécessaire
et même généreuse
pour savoir
quel serait
le mieux
chemin pour lui
voilà pourquoi
quand on passe
au prochain paragraphe
il dit
paragraphe 3
en plus de la loi
inscrite
dans leur cœur
ils ont reçu
l'ordre
de ne pas manger
de l'arbre
de la connaissance
du bien
et du mal
tant qu'ils ont gardé
ces commandements
ils ont été heureux
dans leur communion
avec Dieu
et ont dominé
sur les créatures
donc ce qui est important
à remarquer
dans ces récits
ou dans cette
reconnaissance
c'est que
quand on pense
l'homme
dans son état
original
il a été créé
avec les plus
grands des privilèges
relation avec Dieu
imiter Dieu
faculté
et justice
originale
capacité
d'arbitrer
parfaitement
avec la loi
des dieux
dans son cœur
les problèmes
c'est que
Dieu
dans sa grâce
aussi
en plus de la grâce
de nous avoir
donné la vie
et la vie
à l'image
des dieux
il nous a attribué
ses libres arbitres
et il a établi
un pacte
une alliance
avec l'être humain
nous allons étudier
plus tard
nous allons revenir
sur ça plus tard
mais ces pactes
il était
propre aussi
à permettre
que l'être humain
soit en train
d'exercer
sa volonté
de manière parfaite
non seulement
par une espèce
de création
naturelle
car il a été
créé comme ça
mais
par une soumission
volontaire
c'est à dire
il aurait
le choix
de se soumettre
à la loi
de Dieu
de manière libre
et voilà pourquoi
ce pacte
il était important
car c'était
la manière
dont Dieu
a donné
à l'être humain
la capacité
d'exercer
quelque part
librement
son image
c'est à dire
de choisir
librement
toujours
pour ce qui est
bon
bien
et malheureusement
il a utilisé
Adam
cet attribut
qui faisait
partie
de l'image
de Dieu
pour se rébeller
contre Dieu
pour se corrompre
et donc la réalité
c'est qu'il a été créé
dans une position
de rédivabilité
d'obéissance
une position aussi
de béatitude
et de joie
mais malheureusement
il a fait
le choix
de se rébeller
contre la volonté
révélée
de Dieu
donc en renforçant
une loi
qui était déjà
dans son cœur
Dieu a donné
une parole
un pacte
un ordre
c'est à dire
une révélation externe
c'est la même chose
pour nous aujourd'hui
nous avons encore
cette loi
de Dieu
dans notre cœur
mais en plus
Dieu nous a donné
sa Bible
sa révélation externe
et donc là
c'est intéressant
de remarquer
à l'occasion
de l'aidant
l'être mort
à faire usage
de sa liberté
en ayant
un arbitre
parfait
pour choisir
la rébellion
contre Dieu
en se laissant tenter
et en
renversant
l'ordre
de la création
donc là c'est intéressant
aussi
on va voir
les implications
par rapport
au respect
même des positions
car comment
la chute
a eu lieu
donc l'homme
n'a pas exercé
sa fonction
en tant qu'homme
en tant que celui
qui protège
spirituellement
c'est lui
qui conduit
les décisions
c'est la femme
qui a pris l'avance
qui a pris les fruits
c'est l'homme
qui a été
le premier
rédévable
de vos dieux
c'est lui
qui a été
omis
on dit ça
en français
dans l'omission
et qui a eu lieu
tout en voyant
ce que la femme faisait
n'a pas joué son rôle
pour empêcher
ensuite
il va quelque part
se soumettre
non à la parole
de Dieu
qu'il a reçu directement
il va se soumettre
à la direction
de la femme
et ensuite
en prenant
les fruits
il va participer
à ses péchés
et lorsqu'il
Dieu va les appeler
Dieu ne va pas
demander d'abord
à elle
il va demander
à l'homme
qui a les premiers
rédévables
les premiers responsables
et donc tous
ont été engagés
dans un manque
de respect
à la parole
de Dieu
et la constitution
que Dieu avait créée
et voilà pourquoi
même l'image
de Dieu
est fondée
sur ses réalités
et l'image
de Dieu
est restaurée
envers ses réalités
voilà pourquoi
la sanctification
en Ephésiens 5
va remonter
à cette relation
et donc
ce qui est mis
en emphase ici
par la confession
des fois
c'est de nous rappeler
que tant qu'ils ont
gardé ses commandements
ils ont été heureux
dans leur communion
avec Dieu
et ont dominé
sur les créatures
et donc on sait
et on connait très bien
et on reviendra
sur la question
de la chute
et donc ici
nous sommes devant
c'est que la confession
des fois
nous présente
pas de manière
très
on va dire
systématique
pas en train
de décortiquer
et de démontrer
les classifications
de l'image des dieux
dans l'homme
ça c'est un exercice
qu'on fera
pour la suite
mais c'est intéressant
de respirer
cette atmosphère
déjà
par la lecture
du texte
qu'on a fait
et par la considération
de la confession
des fois
donc
je pense que
je vais m'arrêter ici
sinon je ne vais pas
considérer
comme il faut
les prochains points
on va considérer
ensuite
de manière plus objective
les considérations
générales
à propos
de la discussion
historique
et théologique
de l'image des dieux
et mieux comprendre
ce qu'est l'image des dieux
dans l'homme
mais pour l'instant
je pense que
la grande leçon
aujourd'hui
c'était surtout
la pertinence
pour nos jours
et je pense
que c'est important aussi
d'arriver à la conclusion
que
l'abordage
non fragmenté
de l'image des dieux
c'est la meilleure protection
lorsqu'on va étudier
l'image des dieux
car des fois
on va vouloir faire
la distinction
et suggérer
comme les sièges
principaux
par exemple
de l'image des dieux
et l'âme
ça peut avoir
une tendance
de supprimer
la considération
du lieu
du corps
dans l'image des dieux
ou par exemple
il y a
des considérations
qui essayent
de focaliser trop
sur cette intégrité
spirituelle
originale
et qui a une tendance
à supprimer
le fait
que l'homme
après la chute
préserve encore
l'image des dieux
il y a aussi
la fragmentation
parfois
entre
les facultés
mentales
émotionnelles
etc
donc pour nous
c'est important
de considérer
non seulement
le fait
que l'homme
est l'image des dieux
dans son structure
dans son essence
qu'il a des facultés
qui reflètent dieux
mais que l'homme
il est aussi
fait pour fonctionner
en tant qu'image des dieux
et donc la fonction
est aussi importante
qu'elle est
et
et l'image des dieux
n'est pas quelque chose
qu'on possède
à point de perdre
c'est plutôt quelque chose
qu'on a
c'est pas quelque chose
qu'on porte
voilà pourquoi j'hésite
à dire l'image des dieux
dans l'homme
c'est plutôt l'homme
à l'image des dieux
car c'est pas quelque chose
qu'on puisse quitter
de l'homme
et donc c'est quelque chose
qui est insupprimable
lié
à ce que nous sommes
et c'est ce qui définit
notre noblesse
donc gardons
ces trois aspects au moins
de l'image des dieux
un reflet
c'est à dire une relation
avec dieu
j'ai été créé surtout pour ça
c'est la question spirituelle
j'ai été créé
tel que dieu
pour les représenter
en ayant des facultés
des capacités
et je suis créé
pour agir dans les mondes
pour être un représentant
des dieux
et c'est la source
de la restauration
de notre noblesse
le problème de l'homme
c'est qu'on n'est pas
voulant reconnaître
sa coupabilité
devant dieu
il veut
supprimer sa relation
avec dieu
sauf que lorsqu'il supprime
sa relation avec dieu
automatiquement
l'être humain
est en train de supprimer
sa noblesse
le plus grand problème
de la génération
c'est qu'ils ne veulent pas
reconnaître leur coupabilité
telle qu'il faut
c'est à dire
des vents dieux
et de l'autre côté
par là
ils ne sont pas
connaisseurs
de leur noblesse
non plus
donc ils sont
satisfaits
aujourd'hui
de considérer
qu'ils sont
qui les fruits
d'une explosion
par exemple
ou d'une évolution
animale
et nous savons
que l'homme
a besoin
de restaurer
sa noblesse
pour pouvoir
même comprendre
l'évangile
ok
donc on va s'arrêter ici
je pense qu'on aura
le temps
pour quelques questions
si quelqu'un peut prier
pour conclure
je vous remercie
merci